during the final episode of House of the
Dragon season 1 Damon Targaryen Journeys
deep into the Dragon Mounts the volcano
of Dragonstone in search of a new ally
knowing that the coming war between the
blacks and the greens will likely come
down to the respective dragons he aims
to recruit the riderless dragons who
nest on the island to his cause we see
him approaching the lair of the old
Dragon Burma Thor while singing of
Valyrian tune and the dragon seems to
respond quite positively to it belching
fire throughout the cavern but leaving
Damon unburnt establishing contact with
Burma Thor is great for the blacks
especially since a creature is one of
the only dragons who might be able to
challenge bagar however there's one big
question that no one knows the answer to
yet who will ride him the only person in
rhaenyra's faction with Targaryen blood
and no dragon is Damon's young daughter
Reina who could be a suitable match
however it's also possible that a
non-targaryen could claim Verma Thor